*clap clap*
Skrattar du, Förlorar du
Maaannneeeeeeen
Skratta-
The next one that claims my video-
(mfw T-Series overthrows pewds)
That-
Remember the rules, there are three of them: you laugh, you loose. Okay?
But I get three lives- *laughs* I dunno what that was
Remember the rules, it's very important. Also, hit the bell button and subscribe (PLZ HELP DADA BEAT INDIA)
Let's frickin do this guys :)
This one is called: Bantu Holomisa
Man: You give a poor man a fish and you feed
him for a day.
You teach him to hav- to fish you give him you give him
*mentally dies*
*loses a life*
Fine I don't care. (sure ok then)
*pls end me*
What is happening?! (idk man)
As the update says:
You give a poor man a fish and you feed
him for a day
you teach him to a f-f
fish (WHY)
You teeth *smh* ohh man.
Moving on. I still got two lives. It's okay. I can freaking do this. You only get one life, so don't even (oof)
What is the capital city of England? (in romanian)
Oh please, do not whisper the answer. (yeah snitches)
is that really what it says can anyone from Russia please translate just (ITS ROMANIAN PEWDS)
RRRRRRRRRUSSIA (meow)
Thank you very much x2 (Moldavians aren't that stupid)
No, it's England. The capital of England is England. (200 IQ fortnite haha funny)
Everyone knows that
"Der Weg den ich oft in Gedanken g..."
*lady dies* WOOOOOOOOOO
No (yes)
No, I did not laugh. It was...
Not funny. Moving on.
*catgirl singing sweetly to make you go to sleep*
Is this country roads? (no felix)
It is!
(oh my fucking god it is)
*pewds decides to sing along* COUNTRY ROAADS
*cat girl continues to sing it chinaese*
I'm just confused to be honest. Very kawaii desu ne.
Name that I can't read: If nobody wants it, I'll take it"
Pewds: Another Skyrim meme
Another guy: You're too slow. (sanic?) I saw it first.
First guy: I don't think so
Felix: Wow, the quality is so good. I really understand everything that's happened. (yeah too hard to caption)
*dude fucking game ends*
Thank you, Skyrim very cool. Oh look at that. I got a Skyrim bonus heart looks like I'm fine. Excellent
I don't understand
I just don't understand. Is this what TikTok is? Is this the..
the core of TikTok, have we finally reached the bottom?
cause I don't think he gets better than this, this is A+ content
"Leave" "What?"
"You heard me. Now!" "please..."
"... don't do this." "Are you sure you want to do this ,little girl?" "I mean what if what if we're dangerous?"
Wait is that from The Walking Dead?
"What if I am?" Pewds: WHAT?
I forgot complete... that can't be real. Is that real? That...
( its "AGHGH but somebody keeps putting fucking "MEOW" in the fuckin subtitle boxes)
What if I am. wHaT iF i aM
lmao
What if I bit my tongue. I bit my tongue, okay, are you happy? "I like the shirts."
*pewdiepie fuckin dies*
Get it together Felix, you got to show your bros how it's done no more laughing from this so o-on
No more laughing. Never laugh.
Bigger
Bigger Jeff bigger yeah
It's bigger. Yeah
bigger
Bigger yeah
NO
this clip is called Oblivion Walkthrough part 3
"Ma'am ma'am"
"I came in here to find out something about the surgery my doctor wants to do on my heart."
"Well, I know you're upset and you're scared about this angioplasty procedure"
"But we just don't seem to have anything on clogged arteries and balloon surgeries. I'm sorry"
"You know, I may not make it through next week."
And also I have breast cancer. What is this? The Room?
"Oh, that jerk Harold"
"He wants me to give him a share of my house"
"That house belongs to me. He has no right. I am not giving him a penny. Who does he think he is?"
"He's your brother." "He is always bugging me about my house."
"15 years ago, we agreed that house belongs to me. Now the value of the house is going up and he's seen dollar signs."
"Everything goes wrong at once."
"Nobody wants to help me and I'm dying." "You're not dying, mom."
"I got the results of the tests back.
I definitely have breast cancer."
"and I guarantee you as a mother of two boys that I would do everything
Illegal, legal. It doesn't matter what it is to get my children into this country." "Is there a problem with that?" "Yes."
"Yes, you would let somebody rape your child." Oh (woah there)
AHHHHh
She did say anything, she did say anything, okay
But maybe you didn't have to go there right away
I'm just saying
what would you do, if there was a child right in front of you?
Good- good old chuckle.
"Do you sometimes wish that April was a turtle?"
"Did you want to say something?" Eww, look at the child on the left.
*hiss*
There it is, that's epic.
(GET FUCKED PEWDS)
*angrey pewds powering up*
How dare you show that clip
I'm not shane Dawson. If I see your stupid face again, Mr. Duck.
Oh wait, I am duck
"Okay, keem how do you deal with all this drama and not go crazy yourself?"
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH
"That's so funny I actually feel better now" Good meme, good job duck
Me. Did I lose yet? I don't think so. How many, how many lives do I have left? Oh cool.
It looks like I'm winning, epic. "Did Paper Monsters come out before Paper Mario?". "Oh I bet it did." "Hold on, I want to find out."
Is that Paper Monster they're playing?
"Let's see if pay Paul wing didn't rip it off"
"Wait, when did it come out, Lawrence?"
When the paper mario come out
Look that up make sure make sure paper monsters is not a ripoff. Mm came out. Mm. So paper monsters recut
You still don't know when it came out
You should be you should be a lawyer for this company company whole length lair Oh bruger to eat fruits
Emerge me Oh, how do we know which red ripped off what the judge wiki's it was like came up
We didn't tape monsters recut. And is that let's Wikipedia anybody can edit that you
See free report came out in 2013
Does it 64 games came around 2013? I don't think so sir. You betcha with me wrong prove me wrong
Walk over to Paul Wayne don't worry Renison, we're good we'll get out of this don't worry Paul
Turtle with spikes nobody's ever put a turtle with spikes in a video game, please
Wait, there's Turtles of spikes in Super Mario Brothers. What up?
Okay, that was epic
That was a good laugh
Lunch you had one last
Well, I think it's time to in that episode there. Does anyone have a new display? I'm looking to buy a new display
I didn't mean to hit it with a hard part
It was just a meme
Oh god.
yay i did a help on video